merci beaucoup quand la vie conjugale
devient un enjeu politique jusqu'à
maintenant en france la vie politique et
la vie personnelle était bien séparés on
est peut-être en train d'assister à un
changement nicolas sarkozy s'affiche de
nouveau avec sa femme cécilia
le couple est actuellement guyane
ségolène royal de son côté qui vit
depuis très longtemps avec françois
hollande a laissé entendre qu'elle
pourrait bientôt se marier
sandrine rigaux guillaume barbier la
guyane une pirogue un couple qui affiche
la réconciliation cécilia et nicolas
sarkozy des images travaillées façon
roman photo entre glamour et politique
cécilia est de retour et nicolas sarkozy
entend le faire savoir
il s'était engagé à rester discret et ne
plus mélanger les genres une promesse
vite oublié à dix mois de l'élection
présidentielle
au même moment à rennes ségolène royal
se confie à quelques journalistes elle
envisagerait de se marier cet été avec
son compagnon françois hollande
des noces strictement familial après
plus de 25 ans de vie commune
une déclaration qui ne doit rien au
hasard la veille
lionel jospin avait évoqué son retour
elle laisse personne marquer des points
contre elle c'est à dire en gros jospin
dit ce sera très important la position
de monsieur hollande et elle répond à
temps on va se marier donc il reste avec
moi il faut que tu cherche autre chose
qu elle mène une stratégie implacable
qui consiste à avancer pas à pas à
empêcher les autres de me prendre de
l'air et même pendant qu'on dit et a
fait reculer les rumeurs qui ont pu
exister sur le couple il y a à peine une
semaine elle qualifié le mariage
d'institutions bourgeoise aujourd'hui
présidentielle oblige la présidente de
poitou charentes rectifie le tir
un virage calculer très en phase avec la
peopolisation de la vie politique
les corps dit